having a gay son is like finding a
french fry and your onion rings
you know you're like well it's not what
i expected but
i like these too this guy being the
president
it's like there's a horse loose in a
hospital
i think eventually everything's gonna be
okay but i have no idea what's gonna
happen
next and neither do any of you and
neither do your parents
because there's a horse loose in the
hospital
it's never happened before no one knows
what the horse is gonna do next
least of all the horse he's never been
in a hospital before
he's as confused as you are love
love love love love you want to be in
love you want that new love
that's right you want you want that you
want to feel that first kiss again
that's right because that's the only
real kiss in a relationship
is the first kiss that's right all the
rest of the kisses are just
just protocol every other kiss is just
protocol that's all it is
just routine hey you was gone you back
hey we having sex hey i miss you
you all it's all routine the first kiss
is the only real one
because it always happens like in the
middle of a conversation
you don't even know what to talk about
yeah you know and then maybe someday i
was thinking about maybe you know trying
to get the acura
you never know the first kiss is always
like double dutch
you're just sitting there like when do i
get in when do i get here when do i get
when do i get it
because a dick and a gun are very
similar if somebody pulled out either
one right now we'd all be like whoa is
that meant for me
jesus christ don't point it at me damn
dick and a gun very similar both pointy
they shoot things they come in different
sizes you get a pistol or a shotgun i'm
circumcised so i'm sawed off
your christian background is is part of
the the show yes and i wanted to talk to
you about jesus after that well
not the only reason why i bring it up
but some people thought maybe you went a
little too far
you know as far as what well they
thought that maybe you were being
disrespectful to the christian religion
i'm telling you you need to google oh
good lord so did you feel you were
disrespectful or just you you were just
having fun with some of the crucifixes
and stuff like that i don't even know
what yeah i mean
we did maybe two jokes about that yeah
exactly don't you think the catholic
church went a little too far
more so than my cartoon i listened a
couple of jokes i know this is a morning
show you can't bring up all those crimes
you know what
they just they just sort of kept moving
them around you know like those killer
whales at sea world after it kills a
trainer they'll then move it up to
seattle they don't give them their
background
all right i'm not totally following but
i don't think you know what i'm talking
about
it's a morning show i understand the
game
that kid was missed the graduation and
then it was a feel-good story
and we want to leave if you want to feel
good about america you watch the morning
shows you don't watch this you know
and one i was joking earlier if that
kid's story about the graduation was
late night that would have been a whole
different story
what do you think he's still missing we
can't find him all we found was his hat
but you watch in the morning it's great
it all worked out he got his own
personal graduation
like i was in such a great mood look how
yellow this couch is it's like the sun
but again that's what the world is like
people take everything personally i
think the
world revolves around them right
particularly on twitter
i don't know i'm not tweeting anyone i'm
just tweeting okay i don't know who's
following me
i've got 12 million followers i don't
know who's following me they can be
following me without me knowing
right choose to read my tweet and then
take that personally
that's like going into a town square
seeing a big notice board
and there's a notice guitar lessons and
you go
but i don't [ __ ] want guitar lessons
what's this ah there's a number here all
right call that right
are you giving me guitar lessons yeah i
don't [ __ ] want any
fine it's not for you then just walk
away
don't worry about it one of my friends
he only eats grass-fed beef
you realize how crazy that is that means
he gets to pick what he eats eats
that's pretty good and here's the weird
thing cows eat grass
that's what we've messed with our food
when something eats what it's supposed
to we brag about it
that's like saying hey you know my
four-year-old is sober
it's so much bigger than money oh no it
was bigger than money but you know what
i i watched one of these nature shows
one time
and they were talking about how a
bushman finds water
when it's scarce and they do what's
called a salt trap
i didn't notice apparently baboons love
salt okay
so they put a lump of salt in a hole
and they wait for the baboon the baboon
comes
sticks his hand in the hole grabs the
salt salt makes his hand bigger
and he's trapped he can't get his hand
out now if he's smart all he does is let
go of the salt
baboon doesn't want to let go of the
salt then the bushman just
comes takes the baboon throws him in the
cage and gives him all the salt he wants
and then the backbone gets thirsty the
bushman lets him out the cage
the first place the baboon runs too is
water bushman follows them
and they both drink to their field and
in that analogy i felt like the baboon
but i was smart enough to let go with
[Music]
assault
[Music]
i'm trying to like make it so women just
like understand a little bit of
like just to sympathize it's like we're
like sport fishermen that's what i'm
saying
men like to fish and sport fishing is
different from catching
fish for food you just get it you get it
you catch it
and you you know you you show your
friends
because you want them to know that you
you can catch fish
you take a couple of pictures so you can
show people to fish
that you have the ability to catch
and then you release it back into the
water
but a lot of women in here you have
boyfriends or husbands
you were fish that jumped back on the
boat
and just was like flapping looking at me
like
hi i was wondering if you're gonna be
fishing here again next week like
yeah for other fish get off my boat
is that how you treat all the fish you
be like oh
god damn nope
i'm sorry sweetie you're the last fish i
ever wanted to be with now you stuck
stuck with the last fish who was loving
you and fighting hard to be on your boat
then she got comfortable and now instead
of doing this she's like so
we've been together for like a year now
why do you still have a boat you'd be
like
so what's he trying to say i can't catch
fish no more why are you here to get
some fish
because if i lose my ability to catch
fish then you're not gonna find me sexy
no more so you gotta smell
fish on me so that you know i can catch
fish so you can act right
that's like guys you meet your girl she
was a hoe
like had whole like she big old booty
and this and that
you got to let her do that don't start
trying to trump her up and get a fat and
get a foul
because that's why you like her i don't
want no woman that
no other guy is trying to i don't want a
woman
that i can send to the store at two in
the morning
because nobody's going to try to rape
her like i go
go get some bread at three in the
morning hey cut through the alley [ __ ]
because
cause i talk to the junkies they don't
want it dang guys they don't like you